[Music]
that song never gets old to me listen i
know i'm biased but i think oprah makes
everything better when she's in the room
so lucky us oprah is joining us today
why she wants to talk about her
exclusive interview with the delphi cbs
concert special airs this sunday hey
oprah adele performed several never
before heard songs off of her highly
anticipated new album called 30. highly
anticipated is a word and so she told
oprah all about the stories behind the
music look at them in the rose garden
this morning we're getting an exclusive
look at part of that interview in this
clip adele discusses her new song hold
on
another new song of the album is titled
hold on the lyrics of this song are so
brutally honest sounds like you were in
the dark dark dark hours there i swear
to god you say i am such a mess
the harder that i try i regress
i am my own worst enemy
right now i truly hate being me
every day feels like the road i'm on
might just open up and swallow me whole
how do i feel so mighty small when i'm
struggling to feel at all
girl you can write ah thank you you can
write thank you so what was going on
there what was happening how did you
keep the faith when you were at your
lowest point
what were you holding on to my friend
the question is what were you holding on
to
um
my friends always would say hold on when
i would feel like how i'm you know the
lyrics in the verse
but it was just exhausting
trying to
to to like keep going with it it's a
process you know the process of
of a divorce the process of
you know being a single parent the
process of not seeing a child every
single day wasn't really a plan that i
had when i you know when i had when i
became a mum um the process of arriving
for yourself every single day turning up
for yourself every single day
and still running a home running a
business like it's every you know so
many people know what i'm talking about
and it can you know i feel like that as
well i i juggle those things as well
and
it just i felt like not doing it anymore
and also trying to like
move forward
like
bit like with intention not just trying
to get out of it for no reason my feet
are walking through all of that concrete
oh boy all i can say is i cannot wait
until sunday night oprah joins us now
oprah listen i know you like
interviewing people
but i have to say on this particular
interview i think you were super psyched
every time i would call you're listening
to an adult song you're reading
something about adele
you were very psyched about this
interview weren't you
i went into first of all good morning hi
nate haven't met you before hello
nice to meet you
nice to meet you nate well i was very
very psyched tony said hello too oprah
oprah tony
i didn't say anything because i don't
want to step on the adele uh content
that we have coming out of your mouth
right now so please proceed but go ahead
well i was so excited when i first got
the call asking would i be interested in
doing this interview so ben winston and
his team
uh had this idea at first to do it as a
prime time special for cbs the interview
that would lead into the concert and
then they decided which i think was
really smart to combine the interview
and the concert together and i was so
excited i'd never met adele
uh loved her music immersed myself in
all of the music beginning with 19 21 25
all the way up to 30 because they sent
me uh 30 and i listened to all the songs
learned the lyrics and
uh
was just really
thrilled to be able to present this
interview
i know this is saying i was so jealous
that oprah got to hear the music because
i'm like god i can't wait to hear she
had listened to it before the interview
so she has some thoughts on that because
of course of course
but it's so beautifully beautifully shot
can i say this for a second yes
well i want to say that that the the
clip that you all just showed the hold
on clip i think that that song on the
new album uh is going to be
the
national anthem throughout the world for
anybody struggling with anything that
song is so
poignant and beautiful i think it
becomes an anthem for people um yes i
wanted to do it in the rose garden
i had had the sally lapointe team they
make beautiful suits i had them make me
a suit that was the color of my favorite
rose and then i realized she was going
to be wearing neutral i fretted over
wearing uh rose-colored something when
she was wearing neutral i called gail i
said i think i'm going to look like a
peacock gail you said
i like peacocks yeah
the setting is so pretty number one
that's where kirby got married so you
know that's a special place for me but
the thing is it's almost like you
coordinated the roses to go with your
outfits it's so beautifully done so when
you met her for the first time i i it
was hard to believe that you hadn't met
her before what was your impression what
did you think
she seems very friendly
when i'm
when i'm going to do a a a an interview
of significance i always like to meet
with the person before and ask them what
do they really want what is their
intention what do you want because i
don't want to end the interview and you
say oh you should have asked me or i
thought you were going to ask me so i
came here where she was you know getting
getting done with her makeup teen in uh
to this house and uh and met her before
and and and had a little private
conversation about what do you want and
she said you know i just want to be able
to share my truth and talk about what
i've been through and you know express
that in in the most natural way so
that's exactly what happened during this
interview yeah
oprah well first let me say thank you
for saying hello to me and before i get
to my question i have to i have to yes a
milestone for me um i have to say
everybody in my entire family says hello
but when it comes to adele though i've
always said um what you go through will
help you get through she's talked about
her divorce um also being a single mom
what else did she tell you about her
approach when creating this album
well you know i think what she expressed
i think is going to save
so and you're so right about that nate
what you go through helps you get
through i think she's going to really
liberate a lot of people
male female in marriages that no longer
work because one of the things she
shared is that she wasn't miserable
miserable she had an idea of what
her whole life of what marriage and
family was going to look like and then
when she
you know the reality of that was not
really making her happy and so she's
freed herself
from the the marriage but they obviously
still have a great relationship because
they're raising their son together but
she said she wanted to present a happy
person to her son which i think is so
liberating because so many people stay
for the children making themselves
miserable then the children grow up with
a miserable mother so uh i i i i think
that's going to help a lot of people i
think that's true but you got to make
yourself happy and then happy parents
happy kids is a good policy uh but you
know it's interesting we were talking
about the the song hold on we're talking
about uh people being liberated uh and
living our life after divorce but i've
heard adele say that she doesn't want to
consider this to be a divorce album that
there's other songs on there can you
talk about some of those other songs
kind of the happier moments are there oh
yeah
yes of course she talks about she talks
about the fact that really the divorce
was divorcing herself getting to the
point where she could love herself
enough and also talked about her new
relationship with super agent rich paul
and says that this movie by the way was
there she by the way was there doing
that he was right there right there in
the rose garden waiting
and uh she says that this
this this relationship with super agent
rich paul i call him super agent she
didn't um super agent [ __ ] paul is
because is the first time
she has actually
been in love and also loved herself
i i cannot wait but you the other thing
oprah i want you to talk about is can we
please give a shout out to ben winston
what he pulled off at that observatory
can we please that night was so special
and so beautifully done
what can you tell us about i think the
fact that it's magical i think that ben
winston ben winston and team that made
the choice to even do it at the griffith
observatory first of all so fantastic
and then guys we heard that it was going
to it was scheduled for a monday night
filming then we heard less than 10
seconds there was a one
100 percent chance of rain on monday and
so
had to do the homework
in one day in one day they put that on
they didn't get it all right
thank you see you at the next book club
sunday night the adele special thank you
for getting up adele special sunday
night